[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages time to see them what is making
the headlines with
the editor at large of dot co dot uk ian
dund
and the telegraph's assistant comment
editor
olivia utley who will be with us right
through until midnight
so let's see what is on some of those
front pages the metro highlights figures
from the office for national statistics
which the paper suggests may mean the uk
is past the peak
of the pandemic's third wave curved war
that's the lead on the front of the
daily express
on how vaccinations could be building
our wall
of defense the daily mail hears that the
covert vaccine will soon be rolled out
to 16 and 17 year olds
after the government initially indicated
it would only be offered
to over 18s the times
also leading with that all children over
16 will be offered
the jab scotland's preston journal looks
ahead to the final
relaxation of coronavirus restrictions
there on monday
meanwhile the telegraph reports that
forces loyal to the iranian government
have hijacked an oil tanker the asphalt
princess
off the coast of the united arab
emirates the guardian quotes the labour
leader shakir stamina accusing boris
johnson of being
missing in action over the climate
crisis ahead of the cop
26 summit in glasgow later on this year
and the mirror showcases team gb's
olympic success with a picture of
cyclists jason and laura kenny
well we joined as you can see by ian
dunton olivia utley welcome again to
both of you
um let's start with the uh well the
u-turn is how the daily mail economy is
this u-turn on jabs
a bit of a heads-up given by nicola
sturgeon ahead of
what we can only presume is an
announcement here
yeah i mean this is covered in almost
every newspaper i'm mostly on the front
pages of the newspaper so i think we can
be pretty confident at this stage that
we'll be hearing something tomorrow
and nicolas sturgeon obviously gave a
bit of a nod to it in advance
it's a bit surprising that we're talking
about 16 to 18 year olds and because
pretty much everywhere else in the world
when you look at the research this goes
all the way down to 12 and you look what
the americans have done when you look
what the europeans have done
the treatment in south east asia and
abroad it's predominantly about 12 to
18. i mean really there's very little
research being done on just that segment
so it's a bit confusing as to why we
would suddenly see that it's just for
those top two years
nevertheless at least there's a movement
the joint committee on immunization
vaccination
when he put out his report um earlier
last month it was really there wasn't
any sort of quantitative analysis it was
very strange report it went against the
grain and so the more welcome part is it
seems like we're now going to move away
from
that model and start getting on with it
at least in some limited capacity
yeah and i suppose the great fear olivia
is a resurgent virus come september when
schools
universities and colleges go back we saw
it last year then you head to flu season
to living life indoors if you want to
nip it in the bud i suppose this is the
way
yeah i think it probably is the way um
but i do think i do see the logic
actually of restricting it to 16 and 17
year olds
because yes from an epidemiological
perspective there might not be that much
difference between a 13 year old and a
16 year old or whatever
but the point is about choice and 16 and
17 year olds can
make a decision in the same way as 18
year olds perhaps and
okay they're not legally adults but but
you know they obviously have full power
of
of decision making whereas a 12 year old
i
i suppose the argument is probably that
that may get sort of coerced into it and
if you're not
really at risk from the disease at all
then the tiny tiny tiny tiny risk that
the vaccine
poses um might might seem to you to be
not worth it so i think it's important
that people do have a choice but i think
it is probably right that 16 and 17 year
olds who are very very nearly adults
should be given that choice so i think
this probably is the correct decision
yes and certainly the times um
talks about the element of choice as you
raised but the jcvi have been
very cautiously creeping this way
haven't they talking about vulnerable
teenagers first of all
could have the vaccine in now as you say
16 to 18 year olds
what what what is the fear do you think
this you know they've always talked
about the balance of risks haven't they
but
do you think the the sort of the
astrazeneca blood clotting issues
has made everybody quite nervous
yes i suppose that has a bit but i mean
we look we have now have millions of
cases worldwide with people under the
age of six
of 18 taking the vaccine we have almost
no sort of adverse health outcomes
whatsoever
and certainly no deaths as a result from
it we do
have adverse health outcomes from
getting covered even among the very
young i mean there's
quite a high percentage that some people
are operating about eight percent
um of people of under 18 who get covered
will suffer from some form of long coded
that can of course be very debilitating
it can also just be a 12-week thing
so i mean these are these are negative
health outcomes and when you look at the
research you look at what the cdc put
out in the u.s
it was exactly that was comparing look
what are you looking at from getting
covered compared to what are you looking
at from getting the back team and that
did not just operate 16 17 years
it operated from anything above 12. on
that basis they said look this is a very
easy calculation to make and so that's
why i think lots of experts were quite
not all of them there was some debate in
that community but lots of experts are
really quite confused by
why the joint committee came up with its
original assessment which it now seems
to be slowly walking back
uh let's move on to the metro um we've
all wanted to know when it might be
when the peak is passed it feels always
like a significant moment
certainly we're hearing that
hospitalization's um
that peak feels like it's passed we
heard that news earlier this week
and there is the metro third wave in
retreat um
health data experts suggest that cases
and hospitalizations
are falling despite the the high number
of deaths reported
uh today um is that a moment do you
think to
to go thank goodness olivia or or just
keep and watch and wait and be cautious
um i think it probably is a bit of a
moment to say thank goodness we don't
get many of those moments so we should
probably grasp them
when we get them um i think there is a
chance that you know it will fluctuate
and it might go up a bit
again um but the whole point is now
we've got this amazing vaccine rollout
and we've got to trust these vaccines
that it shouldn't matter too much if
cases start to creep up a little bit
again because we know that death rates
really are much much lower and even
hospitalization rates are much lower
it's also quite interesting i found i
find this all sort of puzzling because
we had so many experts telling us that
cases were going to climb up to a
hundred thousand if boris johnson went
ahead with his
july the 19th lifting but it did happen
and
cases are down at sort of 20 something
thousand so
i i i don't know i i think it it's a
moment for the experts to
have a little look at themselves as neil
ferguson clearly is doing
yes they always said there was such
uncertainty because they didn't know how
people would behave
and the suggestion has been that many
people have still chosen for example to
wear face masks ian
or socialize outside and the euros is
now over
and other elements i mean is this
explici is there a simple explanation
for this
no there isn't there's a range of
explanations people are looking at like
you say the euros is
is part of that one of the sort of
techniques they used was to look at the
changes in infections between scotland
and england because scotland left the
euros much earlier
in other words people's caution as you
mentioned
and the other one was schools opening
and there's some sort of moves around
whether people were reticent to get
tests whether they were avoiding them so
they could keep on going on holiday the
ping dammit which we heard so much about
a little bit less now
was actually doing one of those things
of keeping people isolated keeping them
away from each other and may have had an
effect
it doesn't so much that the experts have
to have a look at themselves that's not
how science operates
what you do is you look at the data that
you have and you come up with
predictions that you can
on the basis of that data now on the
basis of the data that we have
everyone including ministers themselves
when they would sort of be speaking off
the record we're obviously thinking you
know
cases are going to go up everyone
expected it now the data has changed so
you come up with new assessments
but i think we can get too excited about
the new assessments you know we will
probably and again we don't know there's
a lot of variables here we'll probably
be looking at peaks and troughs
you know for the next few weeks possibly
into you know as you're going to the
autumn as we're going to school is going
back as we go into colder weather
so you know we will see this process
take place again it's really just about
doing what you can with a tremendously
complicated set of data
the daily express olivia is celebrating
the
vaccine program quoting they say a major
study
that showed that the very nearly 39
million double-jabbed adults are
three times less likely to catch
coronavirus i don't know if that sounds
like a lot or not actually
um but uh but either way they they they
are calling it as
as we've heard from the government a
wall of defense against the virus
yeah it's sort of real-world data i
think showing what we
what we sort of thought we knew from the
clinical trials it does sound
pretty good to me again oh my god i'm
not quite sure how these statistics work
but we were always told that the
vaccines were fantastic at preventing
against severe illness and
hospitalization
the question mark was over how good they
were at preventing transmission
and i think this study suggests that
they are better than expected at
preventing transmission so that's just
another piece of good news showing how
fantastic these vaccines are and better
than anyone could possibly have
predicted
and more evidence showing you know why
we should trust them and
move on with what we're doing yeah well
well that's the big question isn't it
how far people will want to move on
with what we're doing we're heading
towards the end of the summer got all
these questions about travel still have
we not with the review expected
on thursday um whether people should
have confidence now about going about
their lives and
and living normally as we head into the
autumn and winter inn
yeah people are still cautious and i
think they're right to be cautious it's
easier now because it's easier for us to
be outside i mean you know putting aside
the fact that it's been raining
seemingly for the last 12 000 years
it's actually a lot easier to be outside
with you know the work you do for
socializing
the thing that we could be looking at if
we wanted to make people more confident
about what's gonna happen in the autumn
is really ventilation
ventilation is the thing to fix in
offices in schools
that mean that you you know you're not
you're not impacting on anyone you can
go into the school you can go to the
offices as if you don't know what's
happening
we're just trying to make sure that
either through mechanical or natural
means
we're keeping the air flowing out of
that building the government has not
been great at this
it's been very unclear on the messaging
it's been going on and on about
washing your hands and you know wearing
visors when these things are nowhere
near as helpful as sorting ventilation
and it hasn't really put the support
either the technical support or the
funding support
for building owners and operators to try
and fix this stuff so look there's still
time now when we're looking at the
autumn when things could look a little
bit more depressing than they do right
now
touchwood they don't one of the things
you would want to do to make that an
easier process is to fix ventilation
yeah it's going to cost money to do it
properly isn't it much easier to say to
children
as i had all last winter is going with
vests and thermals because the window
will be open
seemed to be the great british way of
doing things coming up
uh sakia stammer accuses boris johnson
of being missing in action
over the climate crisis but is he right
to do so more in just a moment
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me now ian and olivia artley welcome
back to both of you
um so uh november loom's large cop 26
olivia
makes the front page of the guardian
this is sakirstama the labour leader
suggesting the pm needs to um pull his
his socks up or his finger out whatever
the saying is
yeah um it's you know of course that is
what kirsten was going to say i'm not
quite
sure what the prime minister could be
doing differently you know he does have
this
10-point plan and i think actually quite
a lot of people are worried that
some of the 10-point plan goes a bit too
far politically there are some things
which
although they would be great you know
reducing net
getting to net zero emissions by 2050
seems politically very very difficult
and
it doesn't really seem certain at all
that boris johnson has got these huge
targets but he doesn't seem to have
a particularly clear plan on how he's
going to reach them and
i'm not quite sure that people are going
to just lie down and accept the massive
massive changes that they'd have to make
to their lives to reach the targets
so i think kirsten are now coming in and
saying we should have more ambitious
targets
um probably isn't hitting a particularly
good note with most of the country
yeah i mean the tricky bit is um as the
labour leader suggested there was
already
dystopia caused by climate breakdown as
many people suggest it's all very well
what we do
but even john kerry uh the us's climate
envoy
says this is really all about china or
if not china about india
there's massively populous developing
countries who still kick out huge
amounts of fossil fuel in
yeah but you know we we don't have any
control over the government of india and
we
certainly don't have a control over the
government of china and neither did the
chinese for that matter
so on that basis we you know all you can
do is see what are you doing at home not
just what you're doing domestically but
what can you
organize on an international level as
best you can i think the real
problem here is that it's much easier to
make commitments
about emissions reduction than it is to
implement them you might remember i mean
this is what david cameron found
you know david cameron would talk a lot
of course you know he was out with the
huskies that's the first time we ever
saw him
it was all about setting these high
targets but when suddenly it comes down
to the business end of what that
involves which
in that case was rising prices for
energy customers
uh he changed his tune to complaining
about all that uh
green and then a swear word so it's much
harder to implement this stuff than it
is to promise it i think starman's
position here
is we get the promises the promises are
fine i mean you're not gonna have to
implement them no matter how
you know insulated from criticism we
think boris johnson is he's not going to
be around in the you know the decades
from now when these things have to be
hit
the trouble is what are you doing right
now to make sure that we might actually
get to that position and that is
it's a bit harder to see exactly what it
is that he's trying to do
yeah i suppose to be fair to david
cameron he had the small matter of the
2007 2008 financial crisis in the middle
of his husky ambitions and his
application of policy
um which probably changed the finance
finances which is the situation we're
currently in of course now with kovid
a quick word on the staycation for uh mr
mrs johnson
in the telegraph olivia yeah well
staycations are so incredibly expensive
these days i'm not sure if he thinks
that makes him sound sort of
down with the people and we know people
can't go abroad so we're going to just
go to cornwall too i remember the
cameron's doing that every year
but actually god if you've tried to go
to cornwall over the last six months
nothing could be more expensive
everywhere is completely booked up
so he's very very lucky if he gets her
that's a peaceful staycation as far as
i'm concerned
yeah let's hope someone pre-thought this
and booked it for them scotland last
year
this destination yet to be announced no
doubt we'll have pictures eventually
ian olivia thank you both very much
indeed